ev tolls four years ago when this air
show was last on the aircraft that some
call flying cars were still kind of in
the early design phase but a lot can
change in four years fast forward to
today and ev tolls are everywhere and
that got me wondering where these
companies think they're going to be four
years from now so to find out i've given
myself 24 hours to try and catch up with
the ev toll companies here at
farnborough air show to see what the
future might hold you ready start the
clock let's go
first on my list was whisk arrow okay so
what we've got behind me is whisks cora
which is their fifth generation aircraft
now whisk is a joint venture between
boeing and kitty hawk and this aircraft
can carry about two passengers with an
autonomous pilot around 25 miles now
later on this year in around the fall
they'll be bringing out their six
generation aircraft which will travel
about 50 miles and carry about four
passengers right now this aircraft isn't
certified to carry passengers so i asked
wisc ceo gary geisin when that might
change so i'm not going to say a
specific date for us because we're doing
self flying which is a bit harder from a
regulatory perspective so no pilot will
be inside with passengers our pilots are
on the ground
so um yeah i'm inside this is do you
know what this is going to have amazing
views um you can literally see right
down the edge not one for if you're
afraid of heights enough for that time
to go see a bigger evita
now this is the vx4 by vertical this can
carry four passengers and has a pilot at
the front it's got a top speed of 200
miles an hour and a range of 100 miles
or at least the company tells me it has
but i'll have to take their word for it
as this one hasn't actually flown yet
we're a few weeks away from our first
test flight campaign we're really at
this inflection point now where all the
technology we need to build this
aircraft exists today in four years time
we're expecting the aircraft to be in
commercial operation so it's gonna be a
super exciting uh next three or four
years i'd love to stay in chat more
stephen but i need to run to the other
end of the air show
looks like we got one here
this is eve made by embraer now this
model's had its wings clipped but when
it's in full production embraer say will
have eight huge rotors that span
overhead and two at the back to push the
ev toll forward the current
configuration that they've got it set up
here
is four passengers with one pilot at the
front the company says eve will have a
max range of 60 miles and a max speed of
around 125 miles per hour now embraers
say that they're aiming for 2025 for
certification of this ev toll and then
by 2026 they hope to be carrying paying
passengers right there's two more on
display here that i want to see let's
pick up the pace a bit
so this is supernova's cabin concept for
an eevee toll aircraft and this is about
as far as the company's got so far they
haven't released designs for the
exterior they've worked in partnership
with hyundai motor group to create an
interior that's supposed to have a kind
of automotive feel this design concept
is so nascent it doesn't even have space
for luggage supine will tell me that
that will come in later design
iterations we plan to have a flying
prototype by 2024 and enter the market
in 2028. okay that's one on display
okay
does this count i think this counts i
mean i'm way too big to fit in it but
this is another evie top this is lillian
and what you're looking at is their
premium cabin design which fits four
people plus one pilot we've now
completed for the most part technology
demonstration so we are now comfortable
with the architecture what it can do and
we're now moving to the
industrialization phase and what makes
lilium's aircraft really interesting is
instead of having like four or six or
eight big rotors to achieve takeoff they
have a whole series of smaller ones and
the company says that this makes their
edtol a lot quieter liliam told me that
they hoped to have their aircraft
certified by 2025 but i was curious as
to whether it would ever be autonomous
autonomy has a role to play because over
time you're gonna want to defray the
cost of pilots we don't see that being
necessary or desirable they want so
there you have it according to these
companies in four years time they'll not
only be certified and flying but also
carrying paying passengers and as for
the autonomous versions of their evita
aircraft well you might have to wait a
little bit longer
[Music]